[Music]
welcome back so before I start talking
about the Fourier transform and the
Fourier series I want to remind you a
little bit about inner products of
functions
okay so we're really familiar with
vector spaces two-dimensional
three-dimensional
n-dimensional vectors of coordinates or
of data but now we're going to be
talking about inner products of
functions and what I want to do here
this is pretty confusing the first time
you see it for some people and so what I
want to do is convince you that the
definition of an inner product of
functions is kind of very consistent
with our definition of inner products of
vectors okay so I'm going to do this
with an example where we're going to
take some functions of X so this is my X
direction and we're going to have some
function f and some function G and what
we're gonna do is we're going to define
the inner product between these two
functions okay so I'm gonna define my
inner product of f of X with G of X as
the integral and let's say that this is
defined on some domain from A to B then
this is going to be defined as the
integral from A to B of f of X times G
of X DX okay now if this was a complex
valued function which we're going to use
later on like if this was some e to the
I Omega X or something like that then
this inner product would have a complex
conjugate over this G so this would be f
of X times complex conjugate of G of X
but for real valued data for real valued
functions f and G the complex conjugate
of G is just G so you can kind of forget
that so don't worry about that right now
okay so this is how we define the inner
product of two functions this
essentially tells me how similar these
two functions are just like the inner
product of vectors tells me you know if
my two vectors are orthogonal then my
inner product is zero if they're very
well aligned I have a large inner
product it's exactly the same thing with
these functions so the two that I drew
here are actually
very close to each other so they should
have a large inner product when I
multiply them and integrate from A to B
okay but what I want to show you now is
that if we discretize these functions at
a discrete set of X locations and we
collect data vectors of the function
evaluated at those positions then this
inner product essentially comes from
that that inner product of sampling so
I'm going to do that right now
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
sample this function f at a bunch of
discrete locations F 1 F 2 F 3 and so on
and so forth all the way up to F n so
I'm going to have n samples of this
function I'm gonna do the same thing
with G so G 1 G 2 G 3 and so on and so
forth all the way up to G N and I'm
going to be sampling these at regular
intervals X 1 X 2 X 3 dot dot dot all
the way up to X n okay and so I'm going
to for now just assume that there's a
constant Delta X that I'm using to
sample between between these points okay
so I think I would have something like
Delta X is equal to B minus a divided by
n minus 1 something like that okay so as
I increase n or as I decrease Delta X I
increase the number of sample points and
that I have okay and so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna think about the inner
product of data vectors containing these
sampled points F and the sampled points
G and I'm gonna show you that as you
take the limit as Delta X goes to 0 as
this becomes infinitely finally resolved
as you recover these functions then you
recover this this function definition of
an inner product ok so let's do that so
my F function is I'm just gonna put an
underbar tota note that this is kind of
a vector of data like we're used to
seeing an N dimensional vector
containing F 1 F 2 dot all the way down
to F n
and similarly I'm going to have G
underbar is G 1 G 2 dot dot dot all the
way down to G and good now it's
relatively straightforward to take the
inner product of these vectors we know
exactly how to do that we have lots of
intuition for how to how to compute the
inner product of these two vectors and
what I'm going to show you is that when
you do that and then you take n goes to
infinity or Delta X goes to 0 you
recover this exactly ok so let's do that
right now so what we're gonna do is
we're going to take the inner product of
vector F with vector G kind of my data
vectors here and we know that this is
going to be I'm gonna just define this
as G transpose F so what that
essentially means is I take G I knock it
over on its side so let me a draw a
picture it looks like G as a row vector
times F as a column vector ok and what
that means is that I take the first
element of f1 times the first element of
g1 plus the second element of f2 plus
the second element g2 plus f3 G 3 plus
f4 G 4 and so on and so forth ok so this
is a sum from k equals 1 to n of f k g:k
and again if this was complex valued
data this would be g bar and this would
be complex conjugate transpose I'm just
gonna neglect that for now but I want
you to remember that if this was complex
data this would be complex conjugate
transpose and this would be a complex
conjugate on all of these little G's ok
now there's a little bit of an issue
here as as far as I see it which is if I
double the number of data points if I
have two n data points instead of just n
this gets twice as large because I'm
adding up twice as many things so that's
a little strange so what we're going to
do instead is we're going to normalize
this by Delta X which is going to make
it so that if I double the resolution
the
doesn't get twice as big just because I
have twice as many data points okay so
if I look at my f G on my data vectors
times Delta X now what I have is this
equals my sum from k equals 1 to N of F
of K G K times Delta X now what I'm
going to say here is the F K we know
that F K is just F evaluated at XK so
I'm going to say that this is F at XK G
at X K times Delta X and so this is
where kind of it all comes together if I
this is just the Riemann approximation
of my continuous integral up here
remember if this was complex valued data
these would have bars bars this would be
a complex conjugate transpose and so if
I take the limit as Delta X goes to 0 so
I have infinitely fine resolution this
vector becomes infinitely tall and it
contains the whole function from A to B
then this riemann approximation becomes
my continuous integral formulation ok so
i just wanted to show you that this
definition of the inner product for
functions again it tells you exactly the
same information that the inner product
of vectors tells you it tells you how
close these two functions f and g are to
each other how aligned are they in
function space but there's nothing kind
of magical happening here this is just
what you would get if you took the inner
product of vectors of data as the
resolution of that data became
infinitely finally resolved ok so I
think that's really nice to kind of
convince you that nothing fancy is
happening here we're going to use these
function inner products a lot in Fourier
series to represent arbitrary functions
with sines and cosines all right thank
you